Oh Daesan has been fighting against
pollution in China he used to work as a
journalist but now he's one of the
country's best-known environmental
activists who are uncovered a cluster of
cancer cases in the village of hung men
and made it public the villagers call
this cancer street at least one member
of every family has cancer in that
family over there the woman is suffering
from stomach cancer she's bedridden and
here's another case Conger chin has
bowel cancer soon invade June is 0-2 and
this is where Leo yuji's family lives
she has bone cancer we can visit the
family farmer Liu ug is unable to work
she's been confined to bed for years
every time I drink I get a rash and the
water leaves a bitter aftertaste in my
mouth she says I can't eat I don't have
the strength to walk I have these spots
everywhere I feel so weak Leo says that
since she's been ill her whole body
hurts and her bones and joints are
swollen who explains that the doctors
couldn't find out what was wrong with
her until a senior physician at a
hospital in the city diagnosed bone
cancer
analysis of the water in the well showed
heavy-metal levels three thousand times
higher than permitted hoooo takes us to
meet another neighbor son fen Jun has
esophageal cancer my whole body hurts he
says yourself sim you don't look well at
all says son he collected money when
Cong her chin fell sick eight years ago
the family couldn't afford the difficult
operation she needed Kong's husband even
considered selling their daughter to pay
for his wife's treatment who managed to
prevent that Cong lost most of her large
intestine sometimes I can only walk a
few steps she says I can hardly move
when the cancer hurts a lot I would
rather kill myself and carry on living
and suffering like this the cancer
doesn't come at the beginning says who
will first people have diarrhea the
cancer comes later in the liver the
stomach and the bowel ohh
we gather data for 8 years when we
evaluated it we determined that many
more people died here than elsewhere the
cancer rates in the villages of 15 to 24
times higher than in comparable areas
the irrigation canal in the village is a
stinking cocktail of toxins the sediment
contains heavy metals and many
carcinogenic chemical compounds which
have been washed in by the hue River
farmers abused the contaminated water on
their fields for decades it finally
reached the groundwater and from there
the world's almost all the rivers in
eastern China have become gigantic
sewers for the largest industrial area
in the world thousands of companies pump
toxins into the country's rivers to this
day and the effects are hitting everyone
who lives near the river they're not
limited to factory workers
who and Ison has set up a base for his
campaign to save the hue River in his
home city of shenshu
it's a center for fellow activists he
spent the past decade documenting the
environmental abuses Poole publishes a
blog and state media also carry his
reports he's even won prizes for his
photos in China that helps him finance
his work private donors also support his
efforts but most of the time money is
tight
his sons often help him at work but
things can get quite dicey this mission
would have been life-threatening without
a breathing mask Horace says that only
two weeks after these pictures were
taken and only a little further
downstream farmers went to the river to
get water for their fields there was a
lot of foam when they tried to scoop it
away with their buckets he says but that
released the stink of the contaminated
water they lost consciousness and
collapsed
it was hydrogen sulfide someone called
an ambulance but it was too late it
ended in tragedy with six killed and
four injured together with his eldest
son who all died son has set up eight
observation posts along the river local
helpers even knew as paragliders to
document new sources of pollution when
they find a case who are rings up the
Ministry of the Environment in Beijing
the local authority is early react to
pressure from the top and sometimes the
water quality improves as a result but
it often takes only a few months before
the pollution returns
who as youngest son Minji studies arts
and helps out with the photography he
finds his father's dedication inspiring
and is painting a portrait as a birthday
present
in the past ten years or more of working
to save the hue River
my father has experienced a lot of
injustice contempt and abuse he's been
beaten up and hurt but right from the
start he's fought vigorously for what's
good it's also thanks to him that
awareness of the dangers of water
pollution is growing in China he says he
bit fagor Chasseur so far whoo oh and
his son have visited 400 villages along
the hue river system and documented the
results of the accumulating pollution
today they want to install a water
purification plant in the village of
Duncan song rule they built the water
tank with the villagers years ago a
Chinese man living in Japan saw a report
about who died son and recommended a
microbiological water purifier because
the technology works they're installing
it in village after village sponsored by
supporters in Japan in recent years
we've installed 28 water purification
plants which are providing around 10,000
people with clean water the rates of
cancer have fallen he says in many of
the villages with the equipment there
haven't been any new cancer cases for
five years we've also spoken to the
water and Technology ministries of the
provincial government he says to make
sure they use this technology where it's
needed that's but they haven't given up
hope that their solution might one day
be applied on a greater scale
a lot of people asked me he says why I
let my sons carry out this poorly paid
environmental work they could earn a lot
more money working elsewhere
but I think there are enough people in
our society who earn a lot of money
what's missing are people with a sense
of responsibility I hope that the
younger generation develops a stronger
sense of responsibility compassion and
respect for life the Chinese government
in Beijing is investing the equivalent
of billions of euros a year in economic
development at the same time the
protection of the environment is being
left to individual citizens who often
have access to very limited funds
who are died son has come to Beijing
he's visiting a fundraiser for a
Foundation which seeks to provide clean
drinking water for schoolchildren it
shied away from criticism and in return
it has plenty of coverage in state media
the well-known blogger Deng Fei set up
the foundation he wants to work with who
or die son and try at last to get more
money from the government but first a
prize is awarded to who die son for his
work in saving the ho a river the
organisation's hoped that if they work
together the environmental movement in
China will achieve more
who died son knows that without state
help tighter controls and a stricter
application of the law to polluters his
struggle will achieve very little
but we'll go whenever I'm out in the
country and speaking to people he says I
feel very sad for well bothered I'll
beat you though I don't eat you that's
the reason why I want to change this
tragedy and make the situation better I
have to do something in this life but
I'll only be really happy if I achieve
something who Oh Daesan has waited for
15 years for state recognition and at
last a commission is coming to visit his
clean water project and to speak to
those ill with cancer